[Applause]
I don't want to be negative but I don't
think anything's ever going to get
better ever again
[Music]
understand me I have no hope
seven
like if you really think a flying Jew is
gonna come back and make everything okay
isn't that like mental illness
better man than me because you have
human kids I have three cats that I love
and in the best case scenario I'm gonna
have to have them all killed I'm gonna
have to kill my friends
and I knew it going in that's how big my
heart is
let me get serious I know a lot of you
know that during coven my girlfriend
passed away TJ passed away and it was
the the most horrible thing that's ever
happened to me and I'm sure to her
the truth is like I'm a guy who talks
about his wife so I I wasn't clear how
that was gonna go how am I going to talk
about that but then I thought well maybe
how about a TED talk I just have to
change my posture a little bit everyone
dies
I'm gonna die you're gonna die we all
die I'm Marc Maron
I'm a comedian
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]